all right new game started let's play a
French for change okay what okay let's
try this we at line okay interests
exchanges on d5 right and also it takes
in one move on c5 okay so black should
be okay now he basically just still play
some random moves quickly okay he might
go Bishop e3 here trying to exchange the
bishop
maybe just roughly eight to make this a
bit more difficult it's a bit unusual in
this Queen only eight but it's not
obvious what why should should do here I
have quite good development for the
isolated pawn okay what about 94 just
attacking f2 how does he defend it no it
doesn't it just takes and and gives me
the bishop pair for nothing all right ok
might try to play Knight b5 here
how do i set up my pieces here we should
we should d 7 and look t 8
yeah it's amazing it just plays
everything instantly d4 was just hanging
okay so this one here taking the rook
now so how do I continue here 25 maybe
to check deform then Queen to h5 this
looks like a good a good plan okay yeah
I like this okay I can also go on Bishop
c7.r to threaten here which looks so
quite good now queen h arrived this
looks very nice i also threaten look
texty for now rook t4 text and Bishop f3
and it's made on each one this is
actually not so easy to prevent
white resides ya know move like I just
take on deform play Bishop air three he
is you know I mean I'mI'm threatening
this one here what can I enter so played
this one and if white plays 0 move here
I just take here and it's made on h1 not
much you can do alright thanks for
watching pretty quick game here you only
spend 57 seconds sometimes it's an idea
maybe to think of for a while okay